thank God I came down from that [ __ ]
battery acid would do Monday night
greetings from podcast Ville
it's Thursday the third of October
[ __ ] get up wash that [ __ ] and
thank God it gave you another day to
[ __ ] let the Flies out of the cave
listen the Church of what's happened now
is brought to you by kettle bell kitchen
listen
kettle bell kitchen was started by two
army vets who also brothers their
mission was to change people's lives
through making healthy foods more
accessible eating healthy today is on
everybody's mind right now what when and
how much heat it's hard to know where to
start plus meal planning and prep time
is consuming so you don't want to spend
your entire Sunday chopping carrots and
roasting chickens right this is where
kettle bell kitchen comes in whether
you're vegetarian keto hold dirty or
poleo they got it they sent me a little
grass-fed steak and some bison beef
sliders tremendous it was delicious so
what are you waiting for
feed the champion inside of you with
kettle bell kitchen go to the kettle
bell kitchen calm and enter code church
and get $25 each off your first two
orders for new customers that's 25 hours
off your first two others at kettle bell
kitchen calm pressing code Church the
church is also brought to you by four
hymns calm listen 66% of men start to
lose their hand by thirty five and once
you notice in thinning spots it could be
too late number two you know what as you
get older that little hammer between
your legs it don't work that much
shorter maybe it taps out from time to
time those days are over cuz for hymns
calm is a one-stop shop for hair loss
skin care and sexual wellness for men no
snake oil pills no gas station counter
supplements no more awkward person
doctor visits listen today the church
family can get started with hymns
complete hair kit for just five hours
you like joy what the hell are you
talking about
I'm talking about five hours right now
while supplies last
see website for full details and safety
information go to four hems comm slash
Joey the church is also brought to you
by Tom tonight
you got football my bookie dot AG and
Saturday you got UMC my bookie dot AG
not to mention the immature NHL and NBA
seasons are around the corner my bookie
has faster payouts and more lines than
any sports book period so today right
now let's get this party started
double your first deposit right now
today by using promo code Church CH you
are CH to get a hundred percent bonus on
your initial deposit up to a thousand
dollars visit my bookie dot AG online
today bet when get paid kick this
[ __ ] newly crystal powell's in
the house today
comedian [ __ ] tremendous all-around
young woman thank you
Hales out of the great state of Texas
the one that God created personally
created Texas happy to be here thank you
for having me you look beautiful as
usual never missing a beat bringing that
sisterhood into the [ __ ] church
because we need people calling his
mother [ __ ] all the time yeah the
spirit start complaining some black
people in Chinese this month our spirit
came to me and they're like we need a
black dude on the Chinese chicken yeah
it's good to have you it's good to see
you here we met through kita over a
bully buses uh-huh and it was really
funny I live in a weird world right now
I live in a world that people think I
could [ __ ] heal all that problems and
I can't yeah and you know what man I'm
not looking to do your podcast I'm not
looking to be on your show I'm not
looking to do your show right now I'm
just looking for fights yeah and it's so
weird how people approach you it's
always something and by the way and it
gets old I can you don't we
Sam Tripoli asked me did you get
perturbed when people Bali and asked you
to do rooms and stuff I thought I don't
know you have to get perturbed when they
stop calling you
that's when you get mad right now I love
what's going on
it's the people think they're pulling
the wool over your eyes okay that kills
me you know last week you and I had a
conversation that my wife and I talked
about for two days it disturbed us so
much really I had nothing to do with us
but it's my biggest [ __ ] pet be
[ __ ] with comics yeah I don't like it
I don't like it and you know what twenty
years ago I was the type of dude I'd
want to burn his house and it was a
fight now because of whatever you could
blast them on Facebook the situation was
you went to do a show and Houston not to
put it on blast let's talk about let's
talk about God educate Thomas you know
what happened before now I've been doing
comedy nine years now what you start I
started actually right here in Los
Angeles yeah haha cuz I've always lived
in the valley so haha was and this was
the original one not the new one that we
have now and so that was kind of like my
home club so I would just go around
there doing open mics and just kept on
and stand in the valley and then I moved
away moved back to Houston because I got
married I fell for the dick so I moved
away it went back to Houston but it was
actually better for me because I was
like a big fish in a little pond because
I was coming from LA so that's when I
actually started getting to the Houston
Improv and then that's when I did Comedy
Central with Kevin and when I came back
I was stronger but it what happened in
Houston it was just it was unfortunate
and you know my personality
non-confrontational I don't like to
argue I don't want no beef but I do feel
like if we hadn't have been a full cast
of women it was my birthday show so it
was only females on the show and they
duped us at the end and I go back to
Houston how long were you married for I
was married for five years I'm actually
separated now as we're still not
divorced but I was married for five
years so it's a blessing for me because
you know people don't legally want to
take down a date you're not going off
till you get separated yeah I'm gonna
try to wait i'ma wait time look you know
I got some [ __ ] in me buddy i'ma wait
till I'm at least fully divorced at
least I don't put that on
I want the problem no I was gonna send
at least at least he saved me from some
embarrassment yes so those five years
you went back to Houston yeah it was
like you were running amok because you
had seen what the major is exactly and
now you're in the my Louise appreciated
a lot boys [ __ ] do you think walk I
went back to New York in 93 and did nine
months on this New York circuit and it
[ __ ] happened to be right back into
reality you know in Colorado I was
getting calls from friends they had bar
shows in New York everything was a
Brenda show uh-huh
so I had to sell drugs just to get my
friends to [ __ ] show get the coke for
you
we're gonna meet me arm stuck in the you
know yet to come something New York
Comedy Club just pay the ten bucks I'll
take a I'm taking K just painted bug him
one of my brain is yeah and then I said
[ __ ] this I went to Colorado on like it
it focused everything it mm-hmm
it was like I was doing comedy for two
years on balance going to New York and
seeing the struggle okay into
perspective and I went back to Colorado
like a [ __ ] you know maniac way about
how like one of Duncan's [ __ ]
missiles on a career I was back and I
didn't look back because I knew the
struggle was so you would back there for
five years you got to you did all those
Cody was [ __ ] room to be that whole
you know we even get close you know
Oklahoma Dallas that whole southern
southern route but you're exactly right
it made me appreciate especially now
being back in LA like this is the big
leagues like you can call you know in in
the South in Texas and even like compare
in New York to Denver like it makes you
appreciate the struggle when you get
back to the bigger cities like Los
Angeles I try to have pity parties you
know every now and then be like ah but
then I'll be like [ __ ] you're in the
major leagues like this is this is the
mecca so we
you're not in Tallahassee Florida to
talk about man I can't get up you're in
Los Angeles California at the Comedy
Store you know you're at these
monumental places so I just have to put
on the big girl panties and keep the
pushing you know I got a come up with
the conclusion on getting older
no you're getting old you know and I
can't lie to you I feel it from time to
time you know I faked the phone hmm oh
yeah yeah yeah well it's really weird
okay I'm going on like I really want to
but I'm gonna point my life where you
have to conserve energy because I don't
know what's coming mmm I'm gonna point
my life why am I gonna call tomorrow no
I hate dog this dude fell out of a movie
and your name came up
we need a wish that Lana George let's go
and if I'm burnt out
I'm gonna go on to a situation burned
out mm-hmm so I look at like when I was
an open mic I was burnt out but when
you're an open mic easily by yeah I
supposed to remark that no sleep three
hours drink and smoke and [ __ ] that
chick that's five years of hell
basically you know you know for you in
Texas that means you better get used to
driving everywhere I love driving
Lebanon I was one time yeah from Houston
this is a big day you a day to get jobs
Rossi I was in Houston and my buddy was
at the bar he was a man headliner fell
out Midland I hope the whole team so
outlive them yeah I go and I'm like [ __ ]
let's go wait where are we going and I
agreed to do the [ __ ] drive with this
dude we left him and before doing coke
and then at like 4:00 I slept for three
hours and I woke up and drove in 11
hours yeah that's a Midland yeah that
area that's like 11 12 hours oh my god
you know and you're still not even at
the end of the state I used to go to
[ __ ] Houston uh-huh pay a girl rent
like a deuce to sleep on the couch and I
would live with her from Monday to
wednesday Oh
she lived on Westheimer that's it I
would [ __ ] she'd around the block and
Taco Cabana hey that mother [ __ ]
tacos the breakfast we'll just rock your
world
a area like West time of as close to
Montrose yep which is some of the best
food in the country as far as I'm
concerned I mean that place will fatten
you the [ __ ] up if you let it
and I would spend my whole summer I
would book you know froggy bottoms and
out was Texas data love it yeah love it
yeah love it
Oklahoma City yeah all it it's Isis are
Canada Texas are Canada's where the
magician went up Jerry Rocha said image
is so redneck a magician went up he
ripped the paper in half and people in
the audience like he's Satan they
started throwing holy water and [ __ ] cuz
they're not you know Texas these group
you know there's some of these I never
really had a room a problem in Texas
redneck row one night in Conroe the dude
in front of me started talking [ __ ] and
I flipped the show but I never had a
problem in Texas I did you could say
whatever the [ __ ] you want on the
outside of Texas Austin you gotta be a
little careful there a little uptight
you can't talk about like in Houston you
can't say bush on state yeah you can say
[ __ ] about Trump about Bush no it's a
college hippie tension college hippie
time yeah so how is it like for those
five years being married you know what
it's crazy that's really kind of being
married when I used to hear people say
being married it was the hardest [ __ ] I
was never gonna do it got me closer to
God however it made me focus more on
just comedy but in my situation it was
tough because I'm a woman
you know as you can see and so my
husband at the time couldn't handle you
know if I'm if I get off set if I get
off stage you already know if I do a
great job the host is supposed to come
up and piggyback off what I said let's
make this [ __ ] even funnier blah blah
but you know the host would come up
after me and be like god damn you see
the titties on this [ __ ] I won't [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'd heard meanwhile you know my and
you know he was from New Orleans so I
got him coming from the back of the
stage wanting to kick everybody ass and
in his rightful so somebody's
disrespecting his queen but I'm up here
to do a job so I need you to hold all of
that inside
and it caused me cause prayer that's
really the reason one of the reasons
that I am
we separated because he just he couldn't
handle the disrespect and he'd get mad
at me because I wouldn't let him go [ __ ]
would you take him to your goddamn show
well you know [ __ ] at that you gonna
tell your husband now you can't go yeah
you know why he got to that at the end
it was like man if you can't help yeah
because he couldn't handle it he could
not handle is the toughest yeah part of
being a comic is you become like it's
like I always think about this um I mean
dinner with my wife I know she same
brands before we I'm like what if I
would have been the mob here right now
and tonight I gotta go shoot somebody
yeah like what I joined them off yeah I
didn't have this what I got economic I
didn't have this yeah now I got this and
I gotta make this work
yeah you know when I got married I did a
whole podcast about dirty Israel I made
a mistake I got married I wasn't ready
to get married I wasn't ready to get mad
it was already be a [ __ ] dad and it
caused lives of course anguish whatever
but when you get into Tommy I feel bad
for a comedy partner has to be a certain
type yes and it's like you gotta look at
them after the third date and going
mashes home do I come to your
engineering office with you no you ain't
coming economy with me I ain't cheap
bunion I ain't looking for [ __ ] yeah
it's just a job that was our problem
Yanis and that's the big problem that
win and then then you have the problem
when they're dating you as a man and now
you're in Oklahoma with Kevin Hart and
Raza jo6 other brothers yes he [ __ ]
yeah exactly especially when he can't go
yeah especially when you come on go
Kevin gave me a tour dollar bonus do
yeah what did you do to get that got
more pop I just made a sex tape
you know yeah and think about guys oh
yeah I'm gonna marry the chickens white
yeah oh my gosh it doesn't matter I love
it I gonna do that it's so much fun
wait till you knock the [ __ ] out and
she's home with two ugly kids and you're
on the road selling t-shirts and hats
trying to make ends meet because you and
I both know it
my future yeah you gotta fly the farm
flower to stay for three weeks to break
even because if you go back and forth
with the plane ticket you lost you lost
so once you go to Florida you gotta make
sure you to Miami for live there West
Palm and then during the week you gotta
find somewhere to crash that money comes
out of your pocket you're staying in
Miami next to [ __ ] the survivors from
Bermuda [ __ ] yelling screaming doing
Santeria that's the yeah you know I mean
that's the reality of it that you don't
know these things so how do you explain
that
you know when I'm calling you and I'm
like mom hi crystal are you doing you
got that crying baby on your and you've
been alone all week and I'm like I'm
here with me [ __ ] crazy
you're not gonna be who I met I met Bill
Cosby like Bill Cosby my [ __ ] ass
get your [ __ ] [ __ ] and hell that's
a man that money home you know send that
money Oh cuz I'm sitting about myself
with no money so on Monday you gotta
send money home see how happy that
bitch's yeah go up to five to ten years
ago how is it being married to a
comedian that woman or that man has to
be so secure yes we are yep you see my
wife you've met my wife she's gonna say
you don't my wife will say how long and
take the laundry you might as well do a
laundry while you suck this dick please
please
yeah cuz she couldn't even my wife let
it go after like three days really she
had to you have to let it go she's
involved with were partners she's my
calmly she doesn't the paperwork she
makes the call to the agency does to
come out all but as far as we don't
wonder it shows I don't want to hold
something back cuz you feel you do that
yeah you say something like I took a
[ __ ] in the backyard one time I didn't
tell her immediately
I pulled the joke a couple times never
were back at the bother year we moved
from that apartment yesterday took a
[ __ ] in the back she said was that [ __ ]
that night that she came upstairs you
know there was embarrassed I said yeah
that was the same thing I was the bear
can't yeah it's like [ __ ] am I gonna go
on Facebook at 11 o'clock at night after
I worked a 12-hour shift at a dodge
store get on there and there you are
with your cutoff shirt you can find a
[ __ ] and I'm me and Leah hugging
ya think about that so that's why I give
it to porno husbands common area that
[ __ ] I saw you put on it bubbles up
what's that liquid that you put up and
it bubbles up all the infections
peroxide and monkey blood turban towel
and it get out in 10 years were they
hard for you very hard where's your
accidental he's in Houston yeah you
communicate we still communicate because
the fact my brother told me this because
it was so funny my family from the south
my mother was the oldest of four boys so
all my family's been married for a
hundred years say they don't believe my
[ __ ] can stab you and your throat
drag you down the street and [ __ ] a
[ __ ] in front of your face and they
like well you need to work it out so my
brother was like you know what he showed
up at a comedy show and my brother
didn't know I didn't have time to tell
him and he just said hey whatever you
decide if we love him I love him if you
hate him I hate him but you don't make
another if he wants to be with you and
he wants to work this [ __ ] out
you don't make another big gesture cuz I
moved out here and then I moved back to
Houston and then when it didn't work out
I moved back so we've been in
communication but I'm like if you want
to make this work you got to come out
here because I'm not moving anymore
because I'm really really blessed to
even be able to get back into comedy
because when you leave LA you don't get
a lot of people don't get to come back
this is hard like I said I'm like did
some things I ain't proud of to get back
here you know you leave the line and go
to the
man come back and you're like that was
my spot they're like no and that's not a
start the [ __ ] that's exactly what I
had to do by the time you left and you
came back [ __ ] yeah that's
exactly how the [ __ ] move so
I'm really blessed with that part to be
able to get back and we communicate and
don't get me wrong you know I'm older so
it ain't [ __ ] in these streets I don't
you know I don't have time for the the
games I don't have time no you can't
borrow my car no you can't now if you my
man and we've been rocking you can have
whatever I have and I even get out there
and I'm trenches with you to help but if
you just somebody trying to date me
these brothers that nowadays and white
boys just men you know let me borrow
your car can I borrow some money or can
you help me get on this show and I'm out
here struggling myself so it's nothing
out here as far as like dating
especially in California I said I need
to go to New York or the Texas define
because I like men I like men men I
don't need nobody that I can look at and
be like I bet you I can open-hand slap
the [ __ ] out of him I can't have it cuz
I'm the [ __ ] that'll push it that far
so I need a man man and preferably
nobody in the industry like I want a man
who got some my hands don't need to be
rougher than theirs like I get it your
hands probably a little salt from the
lotion and [ __ ] and I understand that
but I need it to be a callus somewhere
just one you got let me see a soft and
that's okay good I want you to get
exhausted but I need a man man I need a
man like a man it's so crazy when you
say the word man when you're 18 you
think you're a man yeah are you walk
around telling that something awful man
is [ __ ] and I didn't become a man so I
got off cocaine when I was 44 years old
45 years old I became a man really you
think wow I don't for a fact there's a
definition to a man yeah and that's just
be it all-around good guy support his
wife yeah provide a good husband to your
wife listen listen all [ __ ] senators
are all gonna make mistakes yeah I'm not
gonna tell you a bunch of [ __ ] up
but the difference between this marriage
and my first marriage really you know
and a week before my mother died she got
mad at me and she said I want you to do
was a grump to be a man and I always
knew what she got that when I found the
daddy rang in my head and she was on top
of my [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh Oh being money
or nothing like that being a man it's
just a certain quality yeah it's a
certain thing well I just became a man
and since the 45 I'm 56
I've been a man for 11 [ __ ] years you
look good joy huh
you look good it's not even about
looking good I know but I'm saying 456
you look great it's it's it's uh it's
really weird like I down I'm a bet
before that I wasn't a man at all I can
control myself I could support a family
mm-hmm couldn't support him I'm not
ashamed to say that yeah couldn't
support a family I couldn't do nothing a
man looks you know you spit out three
kids
you better get ready have three [ __ ]
jobs yeah you know what that football
used to watch on a Sunday that don't
exist no yeah let's go get it take that
t-shirt and give it back cuz I don't
know what you're talking about
you know men look at things we'll look
men look at things that need to be done
am i doing
yeah this is not tomorrow this is not
today
this is not this is right now and
unfortunately with ours he liked my he
had a business he had a daycare and he I
saw him work this from zero students to
300 but the problem you made this very
good comment like about when before you
joined up mafia you didn't have your
family when I used to date him way back
in the day I was a schoolteacher I was
working at a collection agency so then
we got back together years later and I
said oh I'm a comedian he's like and if
you've never heard of me you're like
okay so I'm going on the road everywhere
I can I'm hunting stages so instead of
him sticking home to stay with his
business he started following me on the
road and then the business started to
you know fall short and then he lost the
business and
don't care what it we've had heated
arguments and it's my fault
you know oh I'm out here supporting your
dreams and following your dreams which
you won't get you don't care about my
dreams I know what the [ __ ] yeah so if
my five years was tough man I don't care
what you gotta do uh-huh you gotta do
your job first yeah you got to put
yourself it's a way to put yourself
first without being selfish I don't care
what you want to do I don't care what I
want to do I don't have no say my life
do you think I have a saying I know your
wife in that baby yeah I do what needs
to be done I don't have to say Rambo
whatever came out I've been dyin I gonna
see Rambo kill some [ __ ] I'm
gonna have a chance to go see Rambo
mm-hmm I could tell my wife and daughter
at 6 o'clock dinner I'm going to see
Rambo I'm taking time away from them so
I gotta find a way to see [ __ ] Rambo
and the movie theater that's the
difference between being a man and a boy
yeah
he's doing what needs to be done we
really don't give a [ __ ] what you like
but you don't like mm-hmm
you know when I was a kid you should've
heard me I don't like steak with that on
it I don't like the white bread with the
things I'll weigh that well my mother
died no well that should I didn't like
laughs wait yeah I had to figure it out
quick so I became a junior man like I
know how to do my laundry and I ran my
own [ __ ] yeah well I wasn't no man I
couldn't cover a rent I couldn't make a
car payment anymore
I wasn't consistent in my actions I'd
have a job in two weeks and quit
regardless of the consequences
well that's not a man yeah you know
these are all little things that men
don't do this is what I'm doing I'm
gonna do it three times a week until
they put me in a casket
hmm this is what you do it doesn't
matter what you want to do what time you
have who's waiting for you it comes to
the point now where it's my family first
in the envelope second you come dirt
everybody everything else that comes
with it comes dirt
my family's first the bag yeah my
envelope is second
laughs everybody else you gotta wait on
line right after you do my podcast in
Santa Monica why it's three hours I
don't have three hours I think we'll see
Rambo first before I give you [ __ ]
podcast I'm gonna go watch Rambo shoot
when I get three hours free like
Saturday my daughter's got a playdate
party at Kyle's party you don't think
I'm gonna see you on Saturday and taking
ten edibles I'm getting [ __ ] up cuz I
don't even have a spots ahead I got date
night with the wife mm-hmm so I'm just
taking that I'm gonna take that hunger
from those animals and taking Ryder good
date then I'm gonna cast out that for 20
grand both night [ __ ] yeah I'm taking
the gun with me cuz the joke is gonna be
a bunch of [ __ ] gonna be
shootin Joker the Joker better not be
playing with Rambo cuz I tell you what I
feel like shooting all these Joker
people because the original joke was
saison Romero let's leave it there all
right say hi Romero was a Cuban dude on
the Batman he was cousins with Fidel
Castro in some way or another saison
Romero check him out look at my
wikipedia says our Romero the original
Joker anything after that is background
[ __ ] music he was cousins with
Fidel wife Wow Fidel Castro I thought
you're making that up
no I'm not making it [ __ ] it up why
would I make something like that up
Wikipedia that [ __ ] yeah those
people are crazy and they messed in a
movie up like I know that all that the
bigwigs for this movie they're like
cringing because it's making people not
oh you run a studio mmm you want a
[ __ ] to get shot cuz that'll
draw them up look at tell people not to
eat opiates because they'll tell you
what do people
everybody wants the best yeah wants to
be I'd be lying so this [ __ ] movie
his mom is the daughter of Jose Marti
his mom is the daughter of Jose Marti
Jose Marti is like a great philosopher
in Cuba that wrote all these things well
he's like second look at the job look at
his face Wow yeah that's the joke that's
a Cuban dude dog that's the original
[ __ ]
Joe Wow and he did it to the T in 1960
why are we are we so we just did the
joke a couple years ago dude yeah yeah
well like we've become like that's why
you don't know either between men kids
yeah there's men at home going I would
see that if you [ __ ] like seven I'm
excited to see remember too but he's
also like seven years old yeah I heard
it from the beginning - and he killed
more people in John winter really okay
John wick is 56 the old a Rambo out
kills him at 70 I don't know he look
like he barely hanging on can you really
save us it was like man my heroes that
man right there Charles Bronson is my
hero
he shot more white people I mean this
[ __ ] would shoot you okay what
was the point he's old oh yeah towards
the end they made death wish for I
walked out a movie theater the tears of
my it was my shame on me for even go
that's what was good that's was too is
good Jimmy paid played the soundtrack
but three he was chasing [ __ ]
they wouldn't even live show him run
it's like in the 70s there was a show on
colcannon
the original Ralphie May okay I weigh
500 pounds he was a cop and you would
shoot him leave like this come on bro
I'm talking eight now watch this going
come on yeah
so this [ __ ] is going ahead with
something like this why bunch of [ __ ]
pounds hey you that ciao yeah did you
five years in Houston yeah you did
everything the joke joy joke joy Ken was
yeah and you know what it's crazy I got
over there with Ken it's a joke joint
because a dude
tried to blackballed me from the improv
just nonsense so I started going over
there that's what made me it was the
best thing no cuz it made me start
producing my own shows and I was over
there with Ken at the juke joint and
that's what actually so I got to see
both sides of it I got to see okay now I
got the stage side but now I got the
other side when it comes to booking
comics making sure they get in make sure
they make their flights on time making
sure regardless of what the door does
that everybody gets their money cuz I
never want to be that person because I'm
a comedian as well so if you're doing a
show with me regardless if I got to go
in the back of you're like [ __ ] let me
sale some [ __ ] you're gonna get your
money cuz that's the worst feeling in
the world to get that would you tell
them to let me let me let me holla when
you hear that [ __ ] you already know here
comes some [ __ ] so pay your money
and then at the end of the gig I looked
at you and I go can I talk to you for a
second that's it no it's bad it's bad so
what happened last weekend when you
introduced well into Houston I was
worried because as we all know that it
was under water but that was more of the
Kingwood the con road the north side of
Houston but the media had it thinking
that Houston was under water so it was
my birthday so I had hit everybody and
said hey I don't have to do this show
I'm just doing this as a celebration so
let me know if y'all are still coming
everybody was like nah [ __ ] we come in
we come in so all my friends flew in
town I had Keanu dance at Kelly Kells
they all flew in town plus I had some
local girls we had well over a hundred
people in there because we're in there
counting because we already know like we
count like how many people in here cool
I didn't even want to start taking shots
and celebrate until I knew that we were
good man at the end of the night that
man passed us $400 for like five comics
and he was like man I'm sorry and I was
like no I was like that's not that's
this isn't what's going on we counted
that was just let the people at home and
the tickets were supposed to be $25 on
the flyer how much were they at the door
he went from 10 to 20 to nothing he even
was telling people if you get a bottle
if you get a bottle I'll let you in for
free and I was like and then he was like
well your people aren't used to paying
they were upset about $20 I said that's
a lie
I was like cause my people that comes to
me they're used to going to comedy clubs
where they know they're gonna pay $20
plus a two item minimum
and my homegirl was like girl came up
there and gave him $25 and they were
like oh are you with somebody and she
was like no and she's like they gave her
half her money back and they just didn't
have good business and also I was
supposed to have I got so many learning
lessons out of this and that's what the
biggest deal it hurts but it won't
happen no more it kicked my ass but I
learned from it I was supposed to have a
door girl they were late picking us up
they told my door girl oh you're good
you don't have to be up here so I didn't
have anybody up there that was saying
hey this is wrong this is what's
supposed to be it's $25 now I can see if
the show it started we will them to the
show
okay then you probably wanted to take
that down but they just they just
completely messed over us didn't pay us
at the end of the day they didn't know
what they were doing with the door they
charged some people ten I think they
might have only charged one person
twenty-five dollars because I was in
there in the back of the 400 that I did
get it was hella tense and he was like
I'd rather take something and nothing I
was like well you don't know comedy I
was like cuz my people are used to
paying $20 at the door and they know
they got it by two items whether there's
some water and some nasty cheese nachos
but you got to get two items and so he
just messed over us and then he kept
saying oh we're gonna bring y'all back
and I'm like do you really think I want
to work with you again after you [ __ ]
over me and then you [ __ ] over me for
pennies imagine if it's a big envelope
you'll kill a [ __ ] damn you after you
doing this over a couple of thousand
dollars that's not cool Danny lied about
the about the about the bar and because
of the fact that I knew the guy in the
back I was back there drinking he was
like oh no no no where'd you get a
thousand he goes Oh y'all did well over
two thousand oh well over two thousand
at the bar so he was like oh well you're
right then the door should have
definitely been y'all should have had
more than that from the door
you [ __ ] think so I mean what do you
do like how do you feel for something
man y'all like let me tell you something
what got me to hear you
you know I've lost your mother I lost
money that's what got me in the comedy
my mother was 56 she had a massive heart
attack in Texas you know when you're in
college you don't know who you don't say
which city you're from you just say oh
I'm from California my roommate was from
California so my mother passed away I
was mad at my family I have a sister
that teeter-totters back and forth with
a drug addiction so my family
was the family small country town we
don't hide it so my mama did everything
in the world to hide the fact that my
sister was smoking crack but everybody
knew it so the doctor had been telling
her hey take a break you know need so
when she passed away I said [ __ ] it to
my whole family call my college roommate
she was actually in Vallejo California
I'm like where's the Hollywood I'm like
where the [ __ ] so I was in the wrong
area and that night when it happened I
was in there crying my girlfriend's was
like [ __ ] don't cry your birthday and I
was like this is the worst birthday that
I've ever had like I can't believe I'm
still going through this [ __ ] and then I
had to have a moment where I'm like
[ __ ] you lost you buried your mama day
before your birthday eleven years ago so
you'll be okay so strap it up learn
don't let nobody [ __ ] over you like that
again and just keep it pushing so for a
second it deterred me like man should I
not be doing shows like should I not be
trying to produce shows but I can't let
that deter me I got to keep going cuz
and just learn from it this life you're
living
yeah I'm pretty basically lived from
let's just be maybe 95 well so for 17
years every time I took a gig because
checks bounced yes checks bounced
you know you learn what he's your friend
you take a check next thing you know go
to a restaurant your ATM card no more
Jesus Christ what happened yeah taking a
day to you just met and now your car
don't work and you run to the ATM and
the ATM telling you have a zero no money
nothing and now you realize that that
cheque you got for 600 hours bounced and
everything else that you paid for
bounced your bills that you had coming
out and then you call the guy and the
guys like are we paid you from the wrong
account you know so far for whatever
they're told mm whatever every gig I got
wiser yeah I got stronger again
not a race is coming by no means I'll
say it I don't do business with Latino
or black books
yeah a racist us man smart yeah my
friend here
crystal powers african-american she
knows I'm not racist but the problem
that you have is you want your money
like you guys when you paint the wall
you want your money but you're gonna
work for eight hours a day you want your
money what would happen if you worked
all week and the guy tells you at the
end of the we hey I know you get 12 an
hour but this week they've got only pay
is six would you just take the check did
you imagine living life in that fear for
17 years so now I know when people lie
hmm yeah well people contact me I say
great let me give you a call him and
don't hit me back and go we don't want
to do it through him so you ain't real
yeah a good life thank you
yeah and people get mad at me I've lost
friends comedy friends over this
situation
but I've also explained to them I got
beat so much yeah for so many years I've
so many different levels that you know
you gotta cover yourself and you got a
family so you can't take them you can't
take those they watch Murphy was born I
had a play for keeps
mmm-hmm playing for keeps don't cover
yourself I'm sorry you got everybody
around me got a pull there oh yeah
cuz I got a baby yeah I'm playing for
keeps I ain't got time to be Nikki
Manning all festival pay my money oh you
know that I can't do you festival okay
every time I leave you gotta pay my
money festivals for different levels is
really good but when they usually was a
draw for their festival they gotta pay
me to pay them yep look I just went
through something four months ago why
call them other folks I have a goodness
of my heart
hmm they just to let you know that the
hustle never ends but what they don't
know is I'm from that hustle think
you're gonna put it on me I see it
coming yeah a mouth
I leave the house I call the book well I
said Tom listen I didn't call it for
spots this week can I do your show on
Saturday night as a guest you know he
goes absolutely how much time you want
to hi Joe
I go I just want to go and then do that
do you know I go on Twitter the next day
it's like I can't wait to see you
saturday night cuz I don't put you on
the flyer and put me on the fly I said
quite a callback and I wait you know
Saturday okay cause I'll be back to five
is said hey not for nothing
I see you put me on the fly you draw
yeah go didn't I call you and tell you
to put me on the special gasigo she had
was telling a mistake I go let me tell
you the big mistake you're not gonna see
me today she wanna cook it yeah and he
called and called who he still calls
every week I don't answer the phone
you brought me weed when they would
wrote me a letter I threw the letter
away and that's good to hear
the strongest word that a comic needs to
learn at some point is no mmm that your
first 10 years mm-hmm your first 10
years you got to take everything no Kurt
I think everything cuz that's how you
know what you want and what you don't
want okay you know you know what what
you will do and what you won't do i'ma
tell you somebody decided when I was a
feature acting you're gonna look at me
and say Joey you're crazy and ballsy and
I stuck to it
I ain't workin Sunday's really I decided
that seven years into the business you
know working on Sundays I am doing it oh
wow I woke up at the Addison improv one
day on a Sunday football was on I had to
walk to some [ __ ] restaurant had in
mind but when I walked back I know do
all this all day for a seven o'clock
show the people who don't really want to
see come because I wasn't working like
with the shitty headliner so they gave
away a hundred tickets and I said right
now I'm not working son and I remember
telling people how it works on these I'm
gonna talent we're all gonna leave him
that
I would tell Rob and bring somebody else
because I got to leave on Sunday what do
you mean I don't work something that's
dope I don't want something that's why I
respect chick-fil-a okay yeah because
they like I'm not dollars on a Sunday
but you know what your fat [ __ ] they
don't care yeah
they stick to their rules that's that
you know I'm doing a bit right now where
people hate chick-fil-a it's not pulling
the car to eat you the chick-fil-a cuz
they're insurance don't cover your
abortion they just don't like gay people
I like gay people I can't agree with
them with that but them that's not gonna
be able to boycott the best
[ __ ] yeah and you know when you
go to Austin all these dumb white people
oh my god I went that barbecuing without
wine for an hour
listen go to chick-fil-a there could be
a line all the way down to Burbank don't
say in ten minutes cuz I got computers
the guy comes up to you by time do you
think your [ __ ] you get to your table
you orders right there yeah they do it
right plus I respect that they got up
one day and said we any work yeah
everybody else
Burger King everybody else is selling
their soul they don't do it I have to
that's the type of guy yeah there's one
day I go I'm not doing that no more and
I will never do it again
all money ain't good money no yeah no
everything has to head what in you
control it you know after the strike in
2007 mm-hmm all I got hit was YouTube
movies mmm not for nothing [ __ ]
movies yeah a lot why the [ __ ] what I
want to do a YouTube movie 400 hours a
day and really beep basically what's
carrying your film yeah you know like I
got to work with all you the directors
there for you that's the movie yeah
dudes wife could see a vet you know
three years I did all those movies they
didn't go nowhere
look at mine DB I got 20 movies nobody's
seen her didn't go no way there was a
favor and I wasn't
mm-hmm I was using as an acting tool
mm-hmm
to get better at acting to learn my way
around the set yeah you've learned all
these things but after a while I didn't
want to do you two films no more I
didn't wanna do you two films that was
getting sick and tired of doing $100 a
day folks mmm so from 2010 even though I
needed the money you said no no and so
that's hard for Ariel yeah no could you
want to work I would but you've proven
to yourself it's a discipline okay that
we've lost in this country it's a
discipline okay this is a discipline
that when you're raised in Japan old
school it's a discipline you know that
this is what needs to be done I'm
sticking to this you know people call me
on it say hey we'll pay you this much
agreed to join karate videos I do it I'm
not smoking on periscope no more once I
move on with some I move on something
I'm done yeah ain't no coming back
there's no well let me think about it
whenever they give you money and you do
something it's like when you go back
with that old boyfriend this time he got
a [ __ ] pregnant like this time we took
it to the next level yeah meanwhile he's
telling you you're the one and you're
how do you feel when you live there when
you leave there how do you feel you
aren't walking in there you were [ __ ]
up then why you can't you dip in
yourself yeah you sit back you go that's
it and that's it this is what I'm doing
this is how I'm gonna do you don't want
to live that life no more you put an end
to it and you move and you don't look
back yeah and I still remember [ __ ]
being broke Jack in 2011 and get the
call from the funny bones mm-hmm and
then go listen you know because I was
opening for Rogan you know if I get the
funny bones if they can all you people
to come see they [ __ ] light off
fireworks the funny bone right clubs
yeah great clubs I love working them but
they're not the improv yeah they're not
a theater and whatever so the funny bone
chain called me some way the I knew when
she does this and they want to offer
like four or five weeks that was like
that's great Wednesday through Sunday
this amount of money and
go everything is great but Papa Lohmann
works on this well I'll never forget
saying that Wow she was good though
then you're gonna get well let's call
you back and they called me back and I
go we'll accept it but it's twelve
hundred your flat Wow so it's gonna be
four hundred for a plane ticket so I'm
walking with eight and I gotta be there
from Wednesday through Sunday morning I
said [ __ ] I've got a job at this Ford
dealership and I went there and talked
about a job and what the piss of the
bowel everything I mean once that make
my mind up about some ain't doing it you
know you you get to the point where you
just not doing it no more yeah you know
I was just getting sick and tired of
being sick and tired
there's a dude there's a book out of New
York I love dearly and I would use him a
lot like I would use them as like my
part-time book mm-hmm if I was doing
anything from Toronto down to Texas I
would call them and go hey I'm looking
to be in this area of these couple weeks
can you book me and he would always call
me I got you something mm-hmm it's only
a feature spot it pays for 50 I get down
there dogs know whole town in 350 this
guy would do this to me constantly I
said one more night in Baltimore
no pay they mail you checked no hotel
what game I am sleeping on the [ __ ]
Park bench until the bus left back at
7:00 in the morning the next day I got
thousands of these thousands of these
and I need to hear them cuz I'll be over
here having a little pity party when I
was in LA already that happened to me
mm
- one I was in LA already
I don't read the MADtv BASEketball they
gave me a gig I didn't you know you
don't ask these questions you're so
enthused with the gig yeah don't ask
you're excited then when you get there
they hate you in a by the way are you
there's no Hotel you called the dude in
New York ain't answering on Saturday
he's out playing golf with the rest of
us [ __ ] goofy buddies yeah and Here I
am in Baltimore and we finished a gay
guy huh got the gig as long as I could
y'all need help with some dishes I took
my luggage and I made look like you have
a ride on my gear I may believe how his
heart broke
I like four hours in my pocket and a bus
ticket that God had a bar I'd bought a
return bus ticket back to New York
thousand it was a window Latino Kings of
Comedy got popular mm-hmm the dude some
black dude oh I promote it when the fire
on the road and a Rita Franklin died
unconscious with everybody he took uh
you knows those toy [ __ ] bouncy
houses mm-hmm he took only made it out
of a castle and he called us the Knights
of comedy the Latino Knights of comedy
and we went to how a Bama although you
know off parts of Houston every gate I
still remember running in Dallas 400
pounds drug-addicted you know how Dallas
is I'm an airport Dallas
you've got to connect to the forehead
doubt it you better be a shape you blue
thirty minutes to get from d-day I'm
sitting on the plane I'm thinking I was
gonna get a heart attack sitting next to
him in the back like we hit but he would
buy us the cheapest cheapest plane
tickets right by the bathroom mmm maybe
sit well this how you guys doing have a
good time and every [ __ ] show America
knowledge I know I told you I was gonna
pay 800 but I can only give you 550 and
you go home heartbroken you needed the
money
I'll catch on the next one yeah call you
for the next one
then this one he told you 800 again and
he would give you 8 but what about the
two from the last one
catch it next time player and then he
did again then that's time he was a
hundred short it was like me
Alex Raymundo was a couple of us then I
would get the positive mm-hmm you know
how much is the gig eight how did you
give me five why I gotta play it well
you gotta get it tough for me to do the
gate so I don't know point in the one
time I got into positive mmm that's
tonight I'm in my room and I hit banging
on the door I open the door there's two
white dudes of black dudes a bunch of
cops I'm like what's going on you know
like mr. Diaz do you know where Baba
buys whatever the book his name is I
don't know I don't he left he didn't pay
the hotel he didn't pay the [ __ ]
radio promotion and he didn't pay the
concert hall we want to know where he is
it's theft
you left thank God I got my deposit yes
I learned if not I wouldn't even you'd
have been there was that for the plane
ticket the five at least and do they
make you feel like you're a diva or jerk
for asking for deposit no they go man
you don't trust me you have to ask for
deposit well I see if it's over 500
bucks and you don't know the people
that's how you know if they're real yeah
see if that happens to you like the
great like I have nope I feel like I
should not even I mean listen I was
getting tortured even after a longer
shot I'm gonna forget going to Addison
after The Longest Yard selling out
Saturday night in a Tuscan that's differ
Arlington never told me the number we
said let's see how the night the week
goes and I will tell you people the
number it was Tuesday - sadly then it
was Wednesday - sad and I had learned
Wednesday Thursday to Friday and boat
shows to slow down on Saturday and 1:00
on Sunday
that's Wednesday Thursday that's
Wednesday birthday this [ __ ]
tre blue was his name looked at me and
gave me a check with 1200 hours and I
looked at him right
has to check battle I said this is one
of your white dudes from the improv
you'd be given a lot more we think that
over before you give me that rethink
that over before you give me that and he
changed it he made the proper
adjustments and I never [ __ ] with him
again after the longest shard this
[ __ ] try now if a Booker would
have called me in there I woulda got 25
plus the plane ticket plus transport but
I didn't have a Booker
so I do everything myself this is the
this is the disadvantages I'm not having
a book not a book you start selling
tickets especially now
nobody's gonna just sign you did you
sell 10 tickets they know when you sell
tickets there's a computer and they look
at every Monday and they start looking
at that oh look I can leave some tickets
he sold any tickets in Michigan on his
website where is he next week he's in
Wisconsin who doesn't Wisconsin I'll
start talking to you cuz this is the
Mafia there's nothing different than the
Mafia calmly when you're a Salesman it's
the biggest damn [ __ ] hmm okay hmm
if you were managed by three arts mm-hmm
and you called your manager and he's the
same manager Kevin Hart has yeah who's
gonna get that call answered back first
look Kevin okay yeah why cuz he's the
draw like he know people are gonna come
and see him without a doubt but since
see this business like any other
business like any other thing in the
world is based on money I've seen the
funniest guys at the store I've seen a
thousand funny guys and they couldn't
figure out they were frustrated they did
a special for Comedy Central it's not to
you get a claw cross a certain way and
reach the masses and make them spend
money for you that you have nothing you
could be the funniest guy in America be
a regular at the store mm-hmm then you
go to Montreal and they'll give you a
deal for being funny and they'll try to
develop a show around you you have no
life stories and then when your show
doesn't get picked up you get thrown out
to the wolves they gonna start from
scratch anyway
yeah and
that's why Kevin Hart gets so much
respect that little guy like me because
Kevin got a deal for the show on ABC him
it wasn't the best show in the world
he got canceled Kevin's feelings got
hurt he sat down in front of a notebook
and he wrote a plan and the number one
thing on this plan is I'm going on the
road for a year straight no weekends off
and $15 a week from every club and I'm
giving away everything for free I don't
want another dime over 1,500 every plane
ticket I want to fill in every ticket I
will tweet tickets free tickets for me
for a year this were poor Twitter
Facebook crazy Kevin did this he did
this for about 18 months every weekend
Wow every weekend give him away the
tickets because he knew exposure
exposure exposure what happens on this
show you know it's like I don't like
sending tapes cuz I know I don't do good
in text Duke though when I do a special
I know my strengths and my weaknesses
he knew this he knew that if they just
came to see me if I can get them missing
if I could retain 2,200 people who
thought if I could retain 20% which is
high hmm so if the club has 500 seats
and you do six shows that's 3,000 people
yeah
what's 10% is 300 people yeah so if I
can retain 20% well I got something to
work with next time around I'll take
another punch to the face next time
around what next time I'm gonna be doing
the punching I get punched so this is
that's the secret of this that you have
to learn how to lay down for a while get
kicked in the stomach yeah somebody grab
your titty yeah it's gone it happens or
somebody smacks your ass or a weight
give you envelope everybody else got any
money no yeah they gonna you know I told
you I started club mix yeah till this
day I could I tell you two stories to
that story
I thank Kwame because Comedy Works is
just give me one spot a month
Oh Kwame was giving me a spot every
and I'm talking about opening up a deal
yeah opening up a Bernie Mac I'll bring
up the site if you entertain I didn't
know these mouths I'm black
[ __ ] one of you if you want me
to tell you I know what they were I knew
Richard Pryor yeah like Laurie I do want
Lawrence I knew those guys can calmly
Jam when I started calming these guys
yeah
and because then today I so friends with
Cedric yeah still friends with Bo we're
talking 1994 club mix on East Colfax I
didn't go one Sunday and they said you
hear what happened last night they shot
four [ __ ] we drove up then it
was still casings around everywhere
machine guns it was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
hanging out or blood hanging out you
know they'd be sitting opposite each
other [ __ ] comedy yeah but he would
always go it's the same deal
$40 do you know I did that room for a
year that my [ __ ] never gave me $40
he never even I think the highest he
ever gave me was 20 and two drink
tickets but you want me to be Madeline
you want me to come on here and talk
[ __ ] about at that time I talk sure the
bottom but knowing what I know now
hmm put me up every Sunday yeah so the
exposure everybody got to see every
Sunday it's a catch-22 wash yeah you
know what other than Seattle is a woman
who waited me she just hated me bro not
everybody likes everybody
there was three main book is Pat Wilson
Donna Richards and this other lady she's
dead now
god rest her soul [ __ ] but but she had
30 wounds this [ __ ] had Sunday through
Thursday soda soda
three of those weeks she could book you
three weeks like if you do the Seattle
comedy competition mm-hmm
you would call her and the week that you
win and you have all she would put you
in the room so you would make anywhere
from 125 to $50 in there mm well you
feech at MC she didn't really care about
that she just always like ah you know
what you're a good feature or headline
you
150mm she hated me and you know what I
[ __ ] hated her so guess what I did I
used it in my advantage
I knew she hated me but there every week
that call me week every month at 9:04
and I wonder what schedule she that I
would give her veils
I just knew her schedules so I would say
Thursday night I want to do the parakeet
bar I want to do a guest part and she
would go that's fine and I would go down
and blow up the room and the elder would
ask me why don't you work this like okay
she don't like me and that would be it
but because of her I did 16 more sets a
month because I would torment her on
Monday so I would do Monday Tuesday and
Thursday but she had a Sunday show I got
it on that again I was the best guest
spot hold and people would say to me why
do you do this don't you want to get
paid I'm getting paid I'm gonna get paid
in 20 years right now I'm just clocking
it I'm just clocked this gets paid for
mmm you're gonna get paid for this today
but one day in 20 years it's like when
your grandmother gives you that $20
savings bond and you're gonna cash that
[ __ ] in at the mailbox and they
give you a doll and you're like what the
[ __ ] becomes 20 oz the same thing that's
what we don't understand so yeah she
used the tower friends [ __ ] Joey Diaz
is a SAP he does my shows for free 20
minutes a but look at him now but in the
meantime I just got stronger and they
weren't my shows that do me so I think
there's no pressure yeah yeah there's no
pressure
oh so who's laughing yeah I member
coming down there like wow like thank
you for letting me do all those guests
I'm a regular at the store now [ __ ] and
just go up and see how to get rained on
by slapped in your face so that's the
thing that's the that's the other thing
what you got coming to you you know and
some people pay before you get there
some people pay on time
club in Boston six weeks to pay them
eldritch Eck
so you have to decide how many times
you're gonna do that first time I did it
I woke up Monday more there was an
overnight
fanox the check was there nice second
time I did it took about six weeks third
time I did it I did Christmas and they
paid me in March never picked up his
calls again even though I like going to
Boston even though I like the crab cakes
he would like to do a [ __ ] thing on
Monday night even though I could do this
room on Tuesday I just didn't do his
room even though he would pay me 600
bucks I refused to do it room you decide
mm-hmm it comes to a point we how much
holiday do you want and it comes to men
this comes to men and women mm-hmm you
got a boyfriend Krystal equal at 11
o'clock he comes over with a bow you
talk for 10 minutes it gives you what
you want you take what you need and then
[ __ ] knows to go home yeah come
over you got a cigarette
you got a light yeah you ain't got no
wine yeah yeah bar your condom or I got
an interview so you gotta realize how
important is this dick or this [ __ ]
I want the drama Liz [ __ ] yeah ready
mate got its own please please quiet by
your family I don't wanna hear by your
mother's winnebago I don't care about
your family's dog I don't give a [ __ ]
about no - yeah it's the same with
comedy how much drama do you want in the
beginning you know take all the comedy
they want Tommy's an abusive partner in
the beginning this is domestic violence
at its highest this is the comedy makes
OJ look like a [ __ ] baseball Jay look
like a [ __ ] nothing because if you're
doing it right you're suffering if you
is cuz there's nothing worse than
wanting yeah nothing worse than walking
you know and I tell people how many
times they get home from those open mics
and 94-95 crying crying cuz I had not
gone alone it's like I'm
I could become a rocket engineer yeah I
was thirty years old yeah it was running
out of time when I learned to be a chef
of thirty when we're getting a job at
Chili's and learn how to be a waiter
there was nothing else so I would come
home at night and there was a newspaper
and I would circle all the clothing
someday I wish of my vice someday I'm
gonna work giggles and then you get into
the business you like I don't wanna work
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's just weird
so the first 10 years you have to put up
with an abusive part this is abuse yeah
he doesn't care if you're tired he
doesn't care if he's sick he doesn't
care if your mother's in town
about your feelings about your feelings
because that's when you have to go out
and do comic you never see the open like
a drive up to a comedy on open mike
Renault Ferrari have you ever never so
what makes you think that you do comedy
when your life is the hardest when you
can't pay the rent go do comedy you'll
be a funny [ __ ] that's the funny
what is xx I got the rent on the 31st
like [ __ ] I guess God you'll be the
funniest guy in that room because you
learned this is the struggle you need to
go through you need to go through these
struggles he you lost 600 but you
learned you got a $6,000 valuable lesson
yeah so how long have you been back in
LA now February will be two years really
yeah how does it know what did you hook
up with Kevin they put you in a little
special that was a four years ago that
was like my second year in Houston and
then and that changed a lot for me
because I used to you know Mondays I'm
emailing my avails all of that and I
would never get anything back as soon as
I did hard at the sitting people started
emailing me so I've been back here to
two years we will be February but it's
been three since I did heart of the city
so you hooked up with him in Houston
there's no way no hook up there's no way
I would have got heart of the city in LA
cuz you got to realize it's a pecking
order like it's a hundred [ __ ]
ahead of me but in Houston it's just a
few of us so the Pickens is slim there's
no way I've got heart of the city in Los
Angeles if I'd have done it here
because it's too many people he came to
you that's what he does he does it in
each little city like he did Houston he
did Dallas he did Seattle he goes around
he actually he's never done one in
actual in LA he's never done one he goes
around to all these smart small little
towns or cities
no he just does a showcase you have to
you know you have to submit for it and
you like I think it was like 300 of us
and then he'll pick like yeah this big
and then right after that it was great
because they had the Houston Super Bowl
and it was eight hundred eight hundred
of us that supply applied for that and I
was the only comedian of it so I was
like all right so stuff started moving
and I'll tell you when I came back to LA
I came back to LA with credits I was
stronger but it still didn't matter but
you get in line you get in line and I
hang a lot you can ask Keith I'll be
telling her if you tell him I'm gonna
punch you in your head and she was like
no I'll be at the common store crying
like just but then I'll that's why I'm
so happy and so blessed that you know
kids even connected us and all this
stuff that you're telling me today
because I need to hear it because I'll
be in my own head and just be like man I
can't believe I'm going through this and
it's like every great person they
they've all gone through it so it makes
you no different and then I have to
remember like I said earlier I'm in Los
Angeles getting told no if I was in
Tallahassee Florida and they were like
now you can't get on then okay but you
need to take that personal because it's
what you and in Bucky but out here I'm
you know joy is going up you know
Whitney Cummings is going up Alicia
Cooper is going up so [ __ ] get in line
and put your big-girl boots on and just
wait your turn but in the time and that
be ready so when they do call you they
gonna be like that [ __ ] funny one thing
about you I've fell in love with this
day one is that every time I talk to you
you're up to something I'm trying man
you don't ask
yeah I'm just do you know I saw a flier
with you at the portland comedy festival
i was so happy for you yeah you know you
know I see that you're in North Carolina
you do this a couple weeks ago somebody
of white power phone yeah if I was it
God because as an older clown
I can't help everybody know but there's
the people that I see who were going on
their way for themselves I gotta give
them the love they deserve and I prayed
man well I see people going on their way
hmm you get it from me
I have to give you my heart because I
know I was with you right I know exactly
what it is to just make the rent and
thank God you got a day but I feed you
wait till I don't know that it's the
first like a [ __ ] start breaking out
around the 27th 28th I'm like oh [ __ ]
the first has come I can't wait till the
day where I'm like oh [ __ ] is the first
Oh right though I didn't even know cuz
now I you got to start preparing for
that like oh [ __ ] is coming and you know
and the thing with me I went to college
and was a school teacher for about six
days know cuz see my momma was a school
teacher and I had one the mom was dead
she could give you a look like [ __ ]
play with me and these white people
house if you want to I'm about to bust
your ass one of them kind of moms and
that's how teachers aren't now like they
don't pay you no money and they expect
you to raise people's children so I
stopped doing that [ __ ] so the thing
about it is I like I was comfortable but
now deciding I'm choosing the struggle
like I got a degree like I can go out
there and work but I'm choosing to
struggle because this is what I want to
do the nutrition you know grab you the
[ __ ] craziest thing is how once you
fall in love with Tommy he'd be mad but
she love it once you fall in love with
Tommy
I see it in people's eyes i see the pain
in your eyes cuz I had that same pain
yeah and when I was going what you're
doing in eight years now nine yeah well
how is that before you mark I was going
through a divorce with a kid and I'll
have to drop that kid off and forced
myself to go Duke anomaly because like I
said nobody pulls up to an open mic on
the Maserati now nobody [ __ ] pulls up
with flowers and clothes bad drinks and
food yeah
sideout Melissa you he had three [ __ ]
heads and you gotta sit there and take
it like with the banishment so I know
what it was like I know the struggle I
know to be here and finally I got a
little window I got Comedy Store so at
least I can negotiate from the commies
no mm-hmm so Amy she didn't like me
nobody like with the Comedy Store like
all you need is one more [ __ ] like
didn't like me nobody liked me so I did
what I do best I took what I had instead
of bitching about what I did that yeah
instead of bitching about what you ain't
got my [ __ ] swath of the Empire
I'm getting mented by the best there
isn't the business wants to ten
[ __ ] that are hanging out there
I'm wearing I'm taking a little bit from
each one you don't even know what I'm
learning from each one mm-hmm whether it
was Rogen a Dave Tyree or you know at
that time there was a lot of people
hanging out the store Andrew I think
Eddie Griffin I learned the thump from
God from as crazy as he is
Paul moody with his Richard Pryor rape
an ass who I love dearly yeah uh Paul
Moody I learned from watching these guys
and then I got blessed to go on the road
with Richard Jeni Wow and Joe wrote in
it and you know Bobby Slayton and I got
to see different types and I got to
learn what things I wanted to do on the
road no well I didn't want to do all of
the road with Stanhope I went on the
road with everybody call those men see
it you know a paso and you'd learned
learning from each one of you shut your
[ __ ] mouth you take what they give
you they give you seven minutes you know
in those days those Spanish acts would
take twenty wrote twenty Congress on the
road with them well how was that six or
seven hopeless and just until about two
years ago fluffy had like five
[ __ ] really gonna put up to 5
[ __ ] to ten minutes of peace
before you would up because they were
sharing okay you know they were at a
point where they were making millions of
dollars a year
mm-hmm and they could take four guys out
train them you know guys that was
serious yeah we were a team with team
[ __ ] what I would team
yeah I so sure it's you make sure
crystal fine you make sure nobody [ __ ]
with crystal you're the driver you're in
charge of the [ __ ] call everybody
eats remember time when I go on a robot
roping with six of us three of us to go
on stage one of us be hanging out a
bodyguard and a friend and Eddie Bravo
just to talk [ __ ] with him play jujitsu
it you know but he was also on fear
factor making six figures a number sewed
so his road money he didn't give a [ __ ]
you broke even but to have that Rogan is
successful today yes sixty percent of it
is his town but the other forty percent
came from his generosity and his giving
you have to give back
yeah you told me that you have to get
you have to get back for the young
comics enjoy man you had a good saddle
hey that was good you know I'm never
gonna call up to you go hey add this tag
yeah I don't like looking at a my own
[ __ ] don't ask me to look at yours yeah
you know last night I have a red
sweatshirt mm-hmm I have a red hooded
sweatshirt
that's like size 5x mm-hmm it's the most
comfortable good guy okay what I know I
don't have to go out that's the Chicano
and my wife sees I put the rest with you
and she's like oh yeah yesterday I was
seven o'clock I did the podcast with my
daughter
I had a [ __ ] workout the morning I
had to meet some guy taking a beating
you know last night at 7:00 my wife goes
come you that you read so I show her you
better give me a reason I just did not
want to go to the candy store last night
Wow for about three minutes yeah and
then the balls send that message
directly to your brain and it said
listen you [ __ ] piece
[ __ ] go do it you gotta do you know you
were in prison who the [ __ ] are you to
make a decision about what you're gonna
do and what you're not gonna do nobody
asked for your [ __ ] opinion you're
gonna take a three shot of expresso
you're gonna take a [ __ ] half a xanax
for your anxiety you're gonna wash your
[ __ ] you're gonna put that Gration in
your hand and kill the gray and you're
gonna drive down to the store whether
you [ __ ] like it or not
okay do you think I want to go to the
store last night it will install I'm
Thai I was - late before ID pills
running through my system the night
before when vicodins and [ __ ] edibles
I was tired then I got up at 9:00 and
wedding cake box with a bunch of kids
and got beat up his [ __ ] yeah then I met
this kid then I had to go take me a beat
in Burbank and I got stuck in traffic
and then I had no pockets of my daughter
which is just after that she won't shut
the [ __ ] up so I love with her death but
I did not feel like I had the red
sweatshirt on last night which means
popping don't know I never even seen
that sweatshirt
it says Bruin football a Bruin alumni
when you see that I take the socks off I
got these little slippers and I just sit
there scratching my balls liner man stop
when you take that nutsack and just
scratch it this way the whole thing and
I'll sit down switch hands or watch
world lose tonight smell my fingers and
clean out your toes that's what you do
that little gorilla type [ __ ] at that
point that's when your balls go up and
go I gotta do this nobody asked you for
your [ __ ] advice I think I even
called myself a [ __ ] like I was like
nobody asked you for your advice you
[ __ ] if it was up to you you'd be in a
[ __ ] prison in an update you see a
little girl in the room that's what
bosses and the other boss is that
[ __ ] redhead in the room get that
shower wash your [ __ ] and get you ass
down and do this
like the guy that [ __ ] car was like
boy do I feel a lot better yeah once you
go yeah
one should cut [ __ ] off on
Laurel Canyon you like I've had it down
it I left my house my spot was at 10:30
I left it like five to ten that's how
much procrastination I have the same
problems April I believe when I cut to
I'm no better than you no better than we
know better I have doubts I have
insecurities I have anxiety you know I
have the same fears you have I'm just
more experienced than I'm controlling
them and that's what happens three years
or countly and your vocal about it I
know some people that are on your level
that would never be honest and
transparent about having anxiety or
having doubts or procrastination so for
you to even just be that transparent
that just shows you know like you said
that's part of being a man cuz everyone
they won't do that like I've had trust
me especially as a woman I've had men
and I can say this and be honest it
keeps against the test or like you were
so nice to me that first day I had to
come home I was like oh I'll never
forget a text kiss I was like [ __ ] I'm
dying I was like I'm in parts of the
comedy store that I didn't even know
these secret compartments were part of
and I had to ask myself that night I was
like man I was like when it's the other
shoes gonna drop cuz I've had men to
come in my life and be like hey I'm
gonna help but they taking the back yeah
what you gonna do [ __ ] by the way yeah
so just for you to just be that
transparent and then like you said and
you told me flat out like ain't got no
money to give you
but I do believe in giving back and
trying to help and that that's more
that's better than any type of advice
that you can get from a Ledge because I
think you're legendary like I like just
to follow your work and for you to even
just be taking the time that's insane to
me
that's insane but most most people when
they get to a certain level like I had
to do one time I was at a show and I was
pacing I was pacing and he was like man
he was like you're not cut out for this
[ __ ] if you back here nervous and I'm
like dude but now I know that just means
I want to do well that means I want to
do well so badly that I'm sitting here
like thinking okay but that was part of
for Wilmington last weekend I was like
okay [ __ ] you get in there because I
landed at 7:18 the show started at 7:00
I landed at 718 I walked through the
door with my luggage [ __ ] didn't get to
Washington off nothing I had my carry-on
and they said okay we're gonna give you
five minutes I got a glass of water
right when I sat down they were like and
you ready for your headline I was like
damn what happened to five minutes but I
went up there and I killed it and I was
just sitting there thinking man [ __ ]
you are right because usually I gotta
have a kumbaya moment I gotta get in my
head I gotta like sit there and talk to
myself I gotta go take a dump twice cuz
my bubble guts is [ __ ] up but should I
didn't have time and I went straight to
it and it was one of my best show so
it's just part of it but a lot of times
you know people that are experienced or
when they get to a certain level they I
feel like sometimes they lose the love
of comedy because they don't want to do
to [ __ ] no more but they won't be open
and honest and say man I I have those
same doubts to hear that you know it was
hard for you to go to the comedy store
what like your Joe Lee did like man we
all have doubts I feel that the day you
don't get nervous before you go onstage
oh quit paying for you know more if you
don't think I was nervous watching Ali
one last night and then Theo went up to
him and if we don't think I haven't if I
if I was man enough to tell you that
fear didn't run through my heart for a
minute I'm lying to you
same oh yeah they won't do that yeah
weeks ago I was watching Nikki Glaser
mm-hmm prepping for the [ __ ] roast
yeah I seen Nikki Glaser go up she's
done well sometimes she has our brother
not really upset but she tries a lot of
stuff because she's a writer she
levelled the room so hard I was like I
hope I'll have to follow his [ __ ] help
Joe Rogan's in neighborhood and then Joe
Rogan what happened
that [ __ ] proceeded to destroy
I'm dead I'm dead you never signed I
would never imagine what you're dying
you're dying right now the light is on
your insides are cracking yes wrap it up
at all so that's my time ladies and
gentlemen thank you not at that point we
says thank you everything locks up
I could become a paraplegic right there
if I have to
everything should just lock up like just
go yeah yeah nope
alright [ __ ] get up my pants usually
fall on my ass crackers up I pull up my
pants real high and I just died to that
[ __ ] stage go get it as I'm walking
to that stage mm-hmm I'm dying inside
I'm my [ __ ] I can just run out this
[ __ ] going nobody will ever see me
again I'm good I'm good I'll get a job
doing something else until he shakes my
hand once I grabbed that microphone but
I go keep a golf or crystal pile what
what time then yeah now I'm there
man thanks joy yeah man thank you like
yeah this is the truth this is uh you're
a hard worker I admire you and I know
you got a future in this town you know I
sat him watch some [ __ ] Tiffany
Haddish struggle i sat here I said I
didn't want to get married I said he
wants to move to Ontario i sat here and
you know I've been running with Tiffany
Haddish this 2004 2003 but the Tiffany
Haddish hosting how to be a fourth
grader yeah
whatever the [ __ ] with a little cute
yeah a little beautiful simple that she
refuses to take off yeah then why do I
love it she's the sexiest thing in the
world so I've seen it I've seen it boss
I've seen the people with ego that I'm
coming to this town they've pushed him
up and whitened them all up and he's
gonna be a star but they can't cover the
spread and then you see a girl like
Tiffany Haddish that was with an agency
that were lost kept Thomas she wasn't
ready
I had a baby sitting there kids
you're not ready yeah she woke up when
they left them went to another agency
when I says she ready yeah so this is
the reason why we stay here we did just
a lottery ticket to beat them all mm-hmm
but if you don't work for that lottery
ticket that lottery tickets not gonna
taste that good in Italy it can be taken
that easy
yeah take it from you at ease yeah well
you work for it now
chuckles in your pocket you walk over
the Bank of America you slip that
[ __ ] the ATM machine like yeah
it feels that it hit harder I mean you
put the time in you know that the doubts
I have are not because let me tell you
what the doubts I have are the dots I
have before I go onstage not probable to
bomb well be finally is that these
[ __ ] don't want to hear from a
no more [ __ ] like me look at me they
don't want to talk to some old people oh
yeah like anything negative that could
come into my mind will come into my mind
look at your bummy ass Adidas shoes with
your Run DMC from the 82 yeah I swear to
God about a wig gloves on I was getting
ready gone stairs and something just
made me look down I saw my adidas and
I'm like I'm 56 years old still wearing
Run DMC bum ass sneakers what the [ __ ]
is wrong I started an argument of myself
right there messy [ __ ] you're a loser
you got Li Jie's on everything to deter
me that's us yeah we get in our own
[ __ ] way that's us mm-hmm that's I
picked up myself having adidas on either
side all these dudes got these pink
sneakers they look cool I'm gonna be
this like [ __ ] Run DMC at 85 years ago
jobs [ __ ] together
those are legends website
yeah it's crystal Powell comedy and all
my edgy stuff all my social medias
Krystal P comedy but man yeah crystal
peak Amedeo I Love You Man I love your
moxie yeah but what you've done you've
never played the race card on man you've
never played the woman card on man I
know that I got a big set of balls but
more like I told Whitney Cummings
I bet if I could my balls on the table
you'd go chick-fil-a that's I got real
pistachios yes that's why that's why
you're sitting in that chair I
appreciate it
doing what your mother [ __ ] doing and
I
to shoot you know made me cry and ran
like [ __ ] will come your way this [ __ ]
will come in if you do the work might
take 20 mm-hmm might take 15 years might
take 32 years yeah I have a hashtag you
can't lose if you don't quit just you
know and it's okay I can't beat you even
if you quit yeah they can't beat you
that's the beautiful even if I quit they
can't beat me that's a lot even if I
quit they can't be even if I give up
they can't beat me right I got nowhere
to go
yeah this is it I'm like Richard Gere in
office and a gentleman I got nowhere
else to go and with that note don't
forget it's [ __ ] Friday night
Kansas City at the Uptown Phaedo then
Saturday night two shows up at the first
show sold out and they have the second
show at the Paramount Theater and that's
how we [ __ ] do it you cops up his
butt before I let you go a word from our
sponsors listen there's two good games
on tiller maybe one it's maybe one night
tonight's the night
what good is picking games if he can't
[ __ ] win no money
I'll tell you where to put your money
down it you ready my bookie AG NFL
baseball playoffs um see whatever
Chinese ping-pong my bookie has got it
they got parlays they got teaser bets
and if you're looking to bet a little
and win a lot my bookies got your back
they just revamped their site and it's
looking tremendous I encourage all you
to go and take a look if you haven't
already so what I'm gonna do for you
today is this all right double your
first [ __ ] deposit by using
promo code Church CH you are CH and
gonna Tao 100% bonus on your initial
deposit up to $1,000 visit my bookie
online today
that's my bookie and don't forget to use
promo code Church when creating your
account to claim your bonus listen my
bookie you bet you win you get
[ __ ] paid the church is also
brought to you by for hymns calm let me
ask you something is your hairline
slowly starting to move backwards any
bald spots yet
the best way to prevent more hair loss
is to do something by the way he's still
app so it's time to get a handle on
there's precious locks I ask you do you
want a ball spot to pop up on your hand
line and receive do you want to do some
about it first
why do guys turn to weird solutions or
do nothing at all when they could turn
to medicine and science for hems comm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men let me tell
you some snow snake oil pills no gas
station counter supplements prescription
solutions backed by science hims was
created by a guy who knows men's health
easier online that in-person no more
awkward in-person doctor visit or long
pharmacy line for hips connects you with
real doctors online which can save you
hours completely confidential and
discreet you answer if you crest a
questions a doctor will review it and if
they determine what's right for you
they'll prescribe you a medication to
treat the hair loss and it shipped
directly to your door listen for hams
has been featured in GQ men's health
Esquire and playboy get the hair loss
treatment everybody's talking about
something I'm gonna hook you up right
now
nice and easy go-to for hims right now
for five dollars you like Joey five
[ __ ] dollars five hours I'm gonna get
you tuned up right now while supplies
last go to the website for full details
and safety information listen this
treatment could cost you hundreds of
dollars if you went to a doctor or a
pharmacy somewhere else or you got to
take a plane to Mexico no this is for
hips go right now to for hims
dot-com slash Joey and I'm gonna give
you the first month for five dollars
that's for hips fo r hims dot-com slash
Joey I told you guys in the beginning of
the show I love this product I've loved
it I've tried it twice let me tell you
some they sent me a little Cuban port
that would put hair on your chest
kettle bell kitchen like I told you the
beginning was started by two army vets
vets because eating healthy is on
everybody's mind right now what when and
how much they eat it's hard to know
where the hell to start plus meal
planning and prep is time-consuming you
ain't got all day on Sunday to be
cutting chicken breasts and onions and
carrots enough Callebaut kitchen will
help you stay on your diet by taking out
the hassle of shopping and cooking these
meals come right to you twice a week for
optimum freshness freshness plus you'll
never get bored because they offer
personalized menus whatever works for
you
vegetarian keto hold 30 poleo they got
it you can even filter by your calorie
protein fat and Carla bits so you get
exactly the right foods for your unique
needs nobody else does that all the
meals are free of dairy soy and
artificial sweeteners and I'm made from
ingredients that are naturally
gluten-free and unlike other meal boxes
you can order one meal at a time or sign
up for a plan and you could change it up
to any time no long term contracts like
I told you they sent me a Cuban roast
pork it was delicious
the bison beef burger sliders delicious
so what the hell are you waiting for
you've tried everything this is the way
to go feed the champion inside of you
with Kelly Bell kitchen go to kettle
bell kitchen calm enter code Church CH
you are CH for 25 hours of each of your
first two orders for new customers
that's $25 off your first two orders at
kettle bell kitchen comm pressing code
Church I want to thank tell about
kitchen I want to thank for hammers calm
I want to thank my bookie got a G but
most importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] savages they're having our back
and support that's like I said next week
I'll be in Kansas City on the 11th and
then Saturday night the first show sold
out and there's still a couple ticket
stuff to the Late Show at the Paramount
Theatre in Denver where you at next very
beautiful I'm in Spokane Washington
thank you I don't know that it's a
private event it's not on your website I
know it's a private one but yeah
next week crystal power was a pleasure
sisters were compared to their and you
always welcome I appreciate you more
than you know man lay your back don't
forget about us I want to thank the
[ __ ] I want to thank crystal
power but again you [ __ ] for
always having my back and don't forget
to keep your eyes open on re Tom Segura
Rogan and [ __ ] sober October the
original Bert Kreischer make sure
they're not sneaking drinks the smoking
joints me I don't give a [ __ ] about so
October
I'm leaving here to go do a twenty two
bong hits alright stay black see in
Kansas City check this [ __ ] me
Lee